des piliers l'un des socles de notre
démocratie parlementaire et je pensais à
quelque chose de tout à fait différent
c'est que est-ce qu'on a montré les
serres du Sénat à au roi Charles parce
que lui qui est passionné par tout ça
les plantes les fruits etc ça aurait pu
le l'intéresser c'est pas si aux fleurs
le miel qu'on lui offre ben concurrencé
son propre miel à high groove et il fait
du miel et puis beaucoup d'agriculture
biologiques
des années effectivement on voyait que
le pionnier avait déjà des résultats
pratiques tout à fait extraordinaires
écoutez passionnant le roi Charles qui
est attendu dans les prochaines secondes
dans la cour du Sénat vous l'avez vu sur
nos images Gérard Larcher le président
du Sénat et il y a le brun Pivet la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale qui
sont prêts à l'accueillir et on voit
l'arrivée de l'escorte du roi Charles
permettra des forces de l'ordre qui
précèdent a priori cet escort Royal
puisque il est 10h40 et c'est l'heure à
laquelle est attendu le roi Charles qui
devrait donc faire son arrivée
maintenant dans les prochaines secondes
dans la cour de la présidence du Sénat
je vous rappelle que le roi Charles
prononcera un discours dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat ce sera bien sûr à suivre en
direct sur notre antenne à 11h08 si le
programme est respecté à la minute c'est
évidemment un événement c'est la
première fois qu'un souverain
britannique s'exprimera devant
l'hémicycle et on voit l'arrivée de la
voiture du roi Charles Jean descart qui
fait donc son entrée dans la cour de la
présidence du Sénat
[Musique]
entre autres particularités le droit de
conduire sans permis de conduire alors
on n'imagine pas qu'un policier
en direct sur cette image et il y a le
brune pilée qui accueille donc le roi
Charles ici dans l'enceinte de la
présidence du Sénat voilà pour cette
image en direct de Gérard Larcher on
précise peut-être d'un mot parce que
c'est important la reine kamilia n'est
pas là elle a un programme parallèle ce
matin
n'oubliez pas que la reine est décédée
en Écosse et une tant d'adoubée
provisoirement
c'était la première fois que ça se
passait une annulation de chef du
gouvernement depuis 1885 et le règne
en direct sur ces images Gérard Larcher
est le roi Charles qui sont donc dans la
cour de la présidente du Sénat et qui
vont faire maintenant la revue des
troupes vous le voyez sur ces images en
direct c'est la garde à sa républicaine
sur ces images on va écouter tout ça en
direct
Gérard Larcher n'a pas de parapente et
non c'est un chasseur donc il a
l'habitude d'être sous la pluie
[Musique]
voilà revue des troupes faites par
Gérard Larcher le président du Sénat le
roi Charles et Yelle brun Pivet sous la
pluie malheureusement vous le voyez le
temps n'est pas au rendez-vous ce matin
du côté de Paris visite plus vieux
parapluie je te souhaite une courtoisie
très délicate
Gérard Larcher et le roi Charles qui se
dirige maintenant vers l'hémicycle du
Sénat vers le bâtiment du Sénat là vous
le voyez il quitte la cour de la
présidente et ils vont rejoindre
l'escalier d'honneur dont on vous a
parlé tout à l'heure parce qu'elle joie
d'un petit mot oui oui c'est c'est
il est arrivé au petit Luxembourg
qu'elle a résilience du président du
Sénat ou où il y avait aussi le bureau
de Napoléon il y a quelques quelques
siècles et en effet ils vont traverser
cette cour cette cour pour venir
récupérer le salon l'escalier d'honneur
qui va arriver à la salle des
conférences et après dans l'hémicycle et
en effet c'est encore un symbole puisque
on a à la fois le présent du Sénat qui
reçoit en tant que président de cette
maison mais également son homologue de
l'Assemblée nationale on se souvient
qu'en 2004 Jean-Louis Debray qui était
alors président de l'Assemblée nationale
était également venu au Sénat on nous
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure mais je
trouve qu'en effet c'est
une belle parenthèse dans ces troubles
politiques dont vous avez parlé ces
crises c'est un moment d'une de la où en
effet on fait abstraction de tout ce qui
est
shikaya et autres et on a en effet une
une belle parenthèse qui va durer en
effet
jusqu'à lundi la session reprend
évidemment on le voit sur ces images
l'arrivée de Gérard archer des helbrun
Pivet du roi Charles III qui vont monter
ce fameux escalier de Nord peut-être un
mot Quentin avec vous Quentin comment a
réagi l'hémicycle en voyant arriver le
roi oui on a entendu un a de soulagement
lorsque sur les écrans on a pu voir
effectivement le roi arrivé dans la cour
de la présidence et maintenant il y a un
grand silence qui est en train de se
faire et je suis même l'un des seuls à
être en train de parler dans l'hémicycle
mais un grand silence tout le monde
regarde dans un grand silence les écrans
qui diffusent Public Sénat et donc qui
regarde le roi ainsi que la présidente
de nationale et le président en train de
monter l'escalier d'honneur Oriane
entre le roi et Monsieur l'archet je ne
sais pas ce qui se dit il y a pas
apparemment depuis pas mal de temps on
va je ne sais pas si on peut entendre la
conversation
j'étais en français
voilà on a un petit peu du mal à
comprendre ce que je dise Gérard Larcher
le roi Charles effectivement on commence
à changer
la construction de du palais et lui
rappeler que cette salle des conférences
là qui fait plus de 50 mètres de long
auparavant avant les avant le Second
Empire tout début du Second Empire
est-elle la salle des séances de ce
qu'on appelle Sénat conservateur et
devenu aujourd'hui une salle alors qu'on
appelle aussi la salle du trône parce
que il y a le trône de Napoléon 1er
qu'on a peut-être voir tout à l'heure
mais ce qui est aujourd'hui en quelque
sorte l'antichambre de l'hémicycle mais
ça a été longtemps là que se tenait les
séances du Sénat et on le précise juste
pour les gens qui connaissent mal on
peut le Sénat la salle des conférences
elle est juste à côté juste
c'est une sale magnifique
très très Second Empire
et on voit donc l'arrivée du roi Charles
dans cette grande salle des conférences
dans ces lieux c'est quand même pas
courant
alors on le disait dans cette salle des
conférences il y a 18 parlementaires qui
vont rencontrer le roi Charles et on le
rappelle des parlementaires qui sont les
vice-présidents des deux assemblées
ainsi que le président de commission des
affaires étrangères
une autre vice-présidente modem Elodie
Jacky et la forge qui est actuellement à
l'image Naima muchu qui est
vice-présidente
le roi a toujours un mot d'humour quand
il s'adresse aux gens et c'est très
agréable ça non c'est vrai c'est
la vice-présidente la France insoumise
Sébastien Chenu vice-président pour le
rassemblement national ainsi qu'elle
aime la porte vice-présidente également
du rassemblement national
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères
étrangères de l'Assemblée nationale
[Musique]
de défense même si mon homologue vient
de manger Renaissance
[Musique]
fin de le roi qui a rencontré donc la
délégation de députés on va écouter
Gérard Larcher qui va présenter à son
tour la délégation de sénateurs présente
on a un petit peu
en charge ici la mise en oeuvre le sujet
qui vous est cher le développement
durable et la messe de notre dette de
carbone
[Musique]
la vice-présidente
relation j'allais dire de faire
comprendre de travailler par on voit
donc la délégation du Sénat vous ne
voyez au premier plan c'est Roger
carotier vice-président les républicains
c'est actuellement Valérie Létard est en
train d'échanger avec le roi Valérie
Létard qui est vice-président pour le
groupe Union centriste
de la Gironde à bord de vos foyers
également
socialiste Nathalie Delattre sénatrice
vice-présidente également qui est membre
du groupe
erdès le groupe qui comporte toutes les
sénateurs radicaux Pascal grenier
actuellement à l'image qui est membre
elle du groupe les républicains
on charge
qui est l'organisation de débat séance
à côté de Pascal grenier
c'est très compliqué
[Musique]
hier soir
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées on
l'a vu d'ailleurs hier soir à Versailles
Christian Cambon il était il était
présent au dîner d'État donné en
l'honneur du roi Charles à côté c'est
Jean-François Rapin qui est le président
de la commission des affaires
européennes ici au Sénat et puis dernier
monde de cette délégation c'est le seul
communiste présent on en parlait Jean
Garric c'est Éric Bocquet qui est
présent non pas parce qu'il est
communiste puisque on l'a compris il y a
un boycott des communistes mais il est
président du groupe interpalimentaire
d'amitié France Royaume-Uni ici au Sénat
[Musique]
un mot parce que Jean-François Rapin
convoi actuellement à l'image il est
également sénateur du Pas-de-Calais et
évidemment il traite beaucoup des
questions d'immigration l'un des points
de tension entre la France et le
Royaume-Uni bien sûr parce que on on
sait que le Royaume-Uni les migrants qui
arrivent dans les pays de l'Union
européenne du Sud veulent aller au nord
plutôt et que donc le Royaume-Uni tout
en ayant quitté l'Union européenne c'est
pour ça que tous les discours de ceux
qui disent si on était en dehors de
l'Union ça se passerait beaucoup mieux
sont complètement fallacieux puisqu'on
voit bien que le Royaume-Uni qui est
sorti de l'Union européenne et
aujourd'hui confronté à une pression
migratoire et qu'on a cette relation
avec la France aux particulièrement
puisqu'en effet les migrants sont à
Calais pour aller au Royaume-Uni et on
sait également que la politique
migratoire du Royaume-Uni qui pendant un
moment souhaité renvoyer les migrants et
légaux Rwanda a été cassé par la Cour de
de suprême en britannique et que le roi
quelque part sans la voir est assez
défavorable à cette solution tout en
étant bien entendu pas et donc on voit
en effet un président de la de la
commission des affaires européennes et
le président du groupe d'amitié qui est
là parce qu'on est fait ils sont tous
les deux
issus de départements qui sont
limitrophes il y a pas de frontières
terrestre mais de frontières maritime
avec le Royaume-Uni on sait que c'est
une question sur lequel il y a vraiment
beaucoup de négociations avec la France
et entre la France et le Royaume-Uni
d'accord on regarde juste pardon je vous
redonne la parole très vite chez les
parois on regarde juste en direct cette
image c'est la signature du livre d'or
par le roi Charles III qui doit signer
le livre d'or du Sénat et le livre d'or
de l'Assemblée nationale voilà les deux
livres qui nous sont présentés on va
peut-être savoir ce que sous le roi a
écrit sur ces livres d'Orchies savoir je
vous explique simplement le signe de
Charles air Corex roi on l'a vu hier
lorsqu'il a fait lorsqu'il a signé à
l'Assemblée à l'Arc de Triomphe si vous
voulez non je disais simplement qu'il y
avait un accord réel entre la France et
le Royaume-Uni sur ce problème de des
migrants
voilà c'était la dernière étape pour le
roi Charles III dans cette salle des
conférences le roi Charles III qui vous
l'avez vu a donc rencontrer les 18
parlementaires qui ont été choisis ou
regarde on voit en direct le livre d'or
on a bah il a signé voilà tout
simplement signé Charles air comme comme
vous nous l'avez dit l'amitié entre le
Royaume-Uni et la France à une grande
histoire et un futur radieux
et en gardant direct évidemment ces
images de l'hémicycle puisque la
prochaine étape c'est l'arrivée du roi
Charles III dans cette hémicycle du
Sénat où on vous le rappelle sont réunis
300 parlementaires députés et sénateurs
confondus l'hémicycle debout dans le
silence pour évidemment accueillir le
roi Charles III on vous la montrer tout
à l'heure un fauteuil spécial a été
prévu pour le roi qui invente s'exprimer
va écouter la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a elle brune pivée qui
prendra la parole en premier puis le
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher qui
vont prendre la parole pour 4 minutes
chacun est la locution de Charles III
elle est prévue à 11h08 très précisément
dans un peu plus de 10 minutes on la
suivra évidemment en direct Philippe
parois il y a beaucoup de fauteuils qui
sont faits en ce moment il y en a même
un pour le pape après demain à Marseille
qui a été un
l'a fait spécialement pour lui bon mais
c'est pas la même chose mais je remarque
que de notre France républicaine à
partir de demain il y aura deux leaders
religieux le roi Charles avec 85
millions
puisque les chefs de l'exemple des
cannes et le pape évidemment chef de
l'Église catholique mais ça c'est autre
chose
pour noter que l'hémicycle est plein
en 93 quand le roi de Carlos était
arrivé
il avait été on avait été assez déçu
parce que un certain nombre de députés
n'étaient pas présents et là je constate
que tout le monde est là au rendez-vous
du souverain qui s'assied et au bas de
ce qu'on appelle le plateau car au Sénat
le
soir de la santé nationale
je m'étais permis de titrer mon écho
enfin un Bourbon au Palais Bourbon on va
écouter évidemment les applaudissements
bien ici
et
c'est un double hémicycle la salle du
Sénat parce qu'il y a un petit hémicycle
pour le président et le bureau et c'est
là qu'ils sont en train de s'installer
au Plateau
et on voit donc Charles III qui a pris
place sur son fauteuil on va écouter ses
applaudissements l'ovation l'hommage des
parlementaires français à Charles III
voilà
Gérard Larcher qui laisse sa place
puisque vous le disiez c'est la place de
Gérard Larcher et on écoute il y a le
bon Pivet monsieur le Président du Sénat
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés
mesdames et messieurs
pour que la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale prenne la parole dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat
il faut un grand événement
[Musique]
et c'est un effet un moment historique
que nous vivons et un grand honneur que
vous nous faites votre majesté qui
connaît bien la France mais qui vient
pour la première fois en tant que
souverain du Royaume-Uni de
Grande-Bretagne et d'Irlande du Nord
cette visite se devait de comporter une
dimension parlementaire
car il faut le reconnaître si le
Royaume-Uni réclamait des royalties sur
l'idée du Parlement toutes les
démocraties du monde lui seraient
redevable
en France
dès le siècle des Lumières le partage du
pouvoir entre exécutif et législatif et
l'admiration des esprits éclairés
si Montesquieu théorise la séparation
des pouvoirs il en observe la pratique
de l'autre côté de la Manche et c'est
aussi à Londres que Voltaire puis
l'inspiration de ses lettres anglaises
Mirabeau quant à lui plusieurs fois
victimes de l'arbitraire royale vénère
tout particulièrement la Béa Scorpus
britannique et c'est donc sous le titre
d'observation d'un voyage anglais qu'il
publie sa critique des prisons d'État
françaises
dans ce livre il crédite nos voisins vos
sujets
d'un plus grand respect des droits de
l'homme que cette nation a si
glorieusement appris
allusion évidente à la Glorieuse
Révolution de 1688
lui-même publie son pamphlets un siècle
plus tard en 1788 et si l’année suivante
la volonté le même Mirabeau défi le roi
du France en lui opposant la volonté du
peuple incarné par la première Assemblée
nationale c'est tout simplement qu'il
veut acclimater en France le modèle
britannique de monarchie
constitutionnelle
finalement ce sont presque les Anglais
qui firent la Révolution française la
famille régnante n'était pas d'accord et
la France évolua vers un autre système
la République née le 21 septembre il y a
231 ans jour pour jour
ainsi ont toujours vécu nos deux peuples
s'observant
s'influençant longtemps rivaux mais
depuis plus d'un siècle toujours allié
pour défendre la démocratie et les
droits de l'homme
le calendrier mémorial est là pour nous
le rappeler l'année prochaine en 2024
nous célébrons tout à la fois les 120
ans de l'entente cordiale et le 80ème
anniversaire du débarquement nous nous
reverrons donc comme le chantait
verraline pour continuer de sceller ce
pacte d'amitié et selon partenariat qui
nous unit sur ce qui est essentiel
aujourd'hui
la guerre est revenue sur le sol
européen
et dès lors que les valeurs les plus
fondamentales se trouvent menacées par
un usage illégal et illégitime de la
force nos deux pays se retrouvent une
fois de plus du même côté celui du droit
international et du respect des droits
de l'homme
deux membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies deux membres
de l'OTAN de démocratie d'influence
capable de s'entendre cela compte dans
un monde en proie aux tentatives de
déstabilisation et de désinformation
enfin en tant que femme
première présidente d'une assemblée
parlementaire française je voudrais
saluer la mémoire de ces femmes qui
plutôt qu'en France ont su faire évoluer
les mentalités pour que soit reconnue
les mêmes droits aux deux moitiés du
genre humain
j'aurais donc une pensée pour ces
suffragettes anglaises qui observe gain
de cause dès 1918 et je veux croire que
c'est en observant les femmes
britanniques leur engagement leur
civisme dans les épreuves de la guerre
et du Blitz que le général de Gaulle
signal ordonnance du 21 avril 21 avril
1944 qui rendit enfin les Françaises
électrices et éligibles
à Londres aussi pendant la guerre un
jeune français qui avait rejoint la
France Libre découvrit qu'on pouvait
acheter en pharmacie des produits
anti-conceptionnels permettant aux
femmes de contrôler leur natalité il
s'appelait Lucien navire future député
et futur sénateurs qui obtiendra en 1967
la légalisation de la pilule en France
au moment où dans le monde et jusque
dans de grandes démocraties les droits
des femmes sont remis en question sur la
base d'un discours nataliste agressif il
est bon de rappeler cet épisode qui est
beaucoup plus qu'une anecdote la liberté
ne segmente pas on est libre ou on ne
l'est pas
et nous voulons l'être dans toutes les
dimensions de la vie
si
nos deux démocraties continueront
d'avancer ainsi vers notre idéal commun
de liberté et de respect de la personne
humaine
chacune à son pas
chacune à sa manière mais toujours main
dans la main quand il faut être ferme
ainsi je sais qu'ensemble nous
avancerons et ferons avancer le monde
sur la préservation de l'environnement
et de la biodiversité cause pour lequel
nous savons votre investissement
personnel depuis votre jeunesse sur cet
enjeu majeur sur cette grande question
du Millénaire
Marianne et Britannia resteront deux
sœurs
comme le déclara Winston Churchill à la
Chambre des communes
[Musique]
le Tout-Puissant dans son infini sagesse
n'a pas jugé bon de créer les Français à
l'image des Anglais
et il disait aussi la France et la
Grande-Bretagne ont trouvé le chemin de
la liberté par des voies bien
différentes mais tant qu'elles feront
cause commune il sera bien dangereux de
les provoquer et bien difficile de les
abattre
il est impossible en quelques minutes de
résumer des siècles de voisinage et de
partenariats multiples mais je sais que
nous nous comprenons pour continuer à
faire ainsi cause commune nos deux pays
qui se sont mis d'accord pour restaurer
et entretenir la Tapisserie de Bayeux
sauront donné une suite enthousiasmante
à cette première bande dessinée de
l'histoire c'est tout le sens de votre
visite et c'est pourquoi je suis fier et
heureuse de vous dire au nom de la
représentation nationale bienvenue en
France
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale monsieur le secrétaire d'État
aux Affaires étrangères au commonwells
et au développement
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
mes chers collègues parlementaires cire
c'est un moment inédit que nous fait
vivre votre Majesté en nous faisant
l'honneur de s'adresser dans cette
hémicycle du Sénat à la représentation
parlementaire française pour la première
fois dans l'histoire multicellulaire de
nos deux pays un souverain britannique
va prendre la parole devant le Parlement
français
réunis dans sa composition bicamérale et
dans sa diversité politique
vous me permettrez de souhaiter la
bienvenue à la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale et à vous tous chers collègues
députés qui siégé aujourd'hui parmi vos
collègues sénateurs
j'ai le plaisir également de saluer les
membres de la Chambre des communes et de
la Chambre des Lords qui se sont joints
à nous ce matin
vous avez tenu cher à réserver au
Parlement français le discours public
que vous prononcerez dans votre visite
d'État
c'est dire l'estime nouée entre la plus
ancienne des nations parlementaires
le Royaume-Uni et le parlementarisme
français
de l'AVH corpus à la Charte des droits
le Royaume-Uni a ouvert la voie au
parlementarisme moderne
il faut avoir assisté comme
Châteaubriand
aux séances du Parlement britannique
pour s’éclamer dans les Mémoires
d'Outre-Tombe je le cite la liberté
contenue dans les limites de l'ordre
sembler ce débattre à Westminster fin de
citation Chateaubriand
la démocratie parlementaire
j'en suis persuadé le plus sûr antidote
pour juguler les passions politiques
et entre nous deux pays c'est bien de
passion dont il s'agit
parfois ennemis souvent alliés
longtemps concurrent le Royaume-Uni et
la France ont distillés
dans les heures sombres le Royaume-Uni
fut un refuge pour tous les Français
contre un exil et fut même un temps en
juin 1940 où la capitale de la France
c'était en quelque sorte transporter à
Londres pour édifier ensemble une digue
commune au totalitarisme et à l'empire
de la brutalité
dans l'adversité se réalisait après bien
les tumulte la vision prophétique de
Victor Hugo qui a siégeait ici sur ces
bancs l'Angleterre toujours sera sœur de
la France
écrivait Victor Hugo
aujourd'hui
alors que nous nous apprêtons à
commémorer au printemps prochain le
80ème anniversaire du débarquement en
Normandie
le déclin du Royaume-Uni demeure
intimement lié
au continent européen
le brexit sire n'y a rien changé
votre nation est un acteur primordial de
la sécurité en Europe
le Royaume-Uni et la France
deux nations de tradition militaires
dont l'une la vôtre n'a jamais été
envahi
sauf par Guillaume le Conquérant
français avant l'heure
oui le Royaume-Uni et la France se sont
à de multiples reprises éprouvées mais
toujours respecter depuis longtemps de
cordiales il y aura bientôt 120 ans elle
se tiennent côte à côte
elles sont toujours difficiles à leur
vocation en se portant au secours de
l'Ukraine
agressé et meurtri
vous avez choisi cire comme la reine
Elizabeth II lors de sa visite d'État en
2004 de vous rendre au Sénat
au-delà du respect porté à la reine dont
je tiens à saluer la mémoire nous
voulons y percevoir un hommage au
territoire de la République que les
souverains britanniques ont si
assidûment parcourus et que le Sénat
représente un hommage à cette diversité
de territoires et de paysages dont la
préservation vous tient si tellement à
cœur et qui constitue l'une des grandes
causes de notre temps
les collectivités territoriales de nos
pays au travers notamment des communes
on nous est temps de relations entre
elles
elles sont le socle le plus solide de
notre amitié
à travers les territoires
se forgent le génie d'une nation cette
idée n'est pas mienne elle provient du
plus français des historiens
britanniques
Théodore Zeldin dans l'histoire des
passions françaises et causé dans le
oui concédons le à notre fierté
nationale il faut bien un historien
britannique de grands talents pour
réussir à décrypter les méandres des
passions françaises
sir sir
rares sont les pays européens qui comme
le Royaume-Uni et la France ont préservé
une même aspiration à considérer le
monde dans sa globalité et tisser autant
de liens de solidarité avec les pays les
plus vulnérables
avec un constat partagé
l'exercervation des fractures Nord-Sud
ne sert que les ambitions de puissance
des gouvernants qui les attisent le
néocolonialisme est de fait d'états
prédateurs et non des colonisateurs
d'hier
la France et le Royaume-Uni dispose des
ressorts nécessaires pour proposer un
autre horizon des coopérations
équilibrées la sécurité un développement
qui soit durable et une attention
particulière à la jeunesse de ces pays
le moment le moment me semble venu de
rassembler les grandes familles du
Commonwealth et de la Francophonie pour
quelle forme quel langage
commun ce que préfigurer avec hum
our qui se confiait à Winston Churchill
et je le cite
plus vous progressez en français et plus
vous comprenez mon anglais
cette formule me va assez bien aussi
pour mon anglais
[Applaudissements]
cire
Sa Majesté la Reine Élisabeth
avait déclaré en 1996 lors d'une autre
visite d'État
celle du président Jacques Chirac à
Londres je la cite s'il est vrai que
nous ne conduisons pas du même côté de
la route
il est tout aussi vrai que nous avançons
dans la même direction
de ce trait d'esprit
qui nous paraît à nous Français si
typiquement britannique so british
nous distinguons une vérité essentielle
nos chemins peuvent être différents
il divergent même parfois mais par une
constante qui défie les règles de la
logique et de la géographie de Londres
il nous ramène toujours à Paris et de
Paris à Londres ainsi s'incline le
cartésianisme français devant l'humour
et l'esprit britannique Sir maintenant à
travers les parlementaires réunis c'est
la nation française tout entière qui
vous écoute merci
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est le président madame la
Présidente
Mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés
merci mille fois pour votre mot très
émouvant
je suis flatté d'avoir été invité par
les présidents de vos deux chambres à
palais ici dans cette illustre enceinte
qui a été d'une manière ou d'une autre
la chambre haute du parlement français
depuis 799
je suis bien conscient que ma visite
précède la rentrée officielle
des deux chambres de votre Parlement et
je ne peux que vous présenter mes
excuses d'avoir
interrompu votre pause
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
très touché par votre présence à tous
aujourd'hui
de votre démocratie ne refléter aussi
dans la langue amitié qui nous nations
et nos peuples
notre partenaire construit sur une
expériences partagées demain absolument
vital alors qu'ensemble nous confrontons
les défis de ce monde
tout simplement le Royaume-Uni sera
toujours un des alliés les plus proches
et un des meilleurs amis de la France
et un monde épouse et moi-même avons
commencé cette visite à la tombe du
soldat inconnu
là nous avons quand même ré tout ce qui
sont tombés pour défendre les libertés
si chères à notre pays
ou que de cette grande nation nous avons
rendu un hommage silencieux et solidaire
debout
avec vous comme nos pays se sont tenus
côte de côte si souvent dans l'histoire
avec cette générosité qui vous
caractérise vous aviez célébré de
platine de ma très chère
comme étant le fil d'or qui liait nos
nations
est décédée l'année dernière ma famille
et moi avons été émue sont comme une
mesure par les hommages qui lui ont été
rendus dans toute la France
ce matin
j'ai relu les traits touchant maux de
condoléances que vos excellence
président de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat ont écrit à cette occasion
vous avez écrit ce Sa Majesté la Reine
comme ayant un cane avec dignité la
permanence de la démocratie britannique
et quel aimait la France la France
l'aimait
je ne peux vous décrire ce que c'est mon
signifier pour moi et pour ma famille
je peux seulement vous remercier et
remercier le peuple de France pour la
grande bonté que vous avez exprimée à
notre égard et à celui de notre peuple à
un moment de telle tristesse
dans la riche
est complexe tapisserie de la relation
entre la France et le Royaume-Uni le fil
d'or que représentait ma mère
brillera pour toujours
je souhaite qu'elle nous inspire à
continuer de tisser des liens entre nous
deux pays avec détermination avec espoir
et avec amour
les exemples de ma grand-mère et de ma
défunte mère
la France
du tissu de ma propre vie pour eux
que je m'en souviens d'ailleurs j'ai été
frappée
en France et à chaque fois que je viens
je suis vraiment marqué frappée par la
chaleur de l’accueil dont je bénéficie à
chaque fois et par toutes les bonnes
choses que nous pouvons faire ensemble
lorsque la France et leur ioni
travaillaient ensemble
l'occasion de ma première visite d'État
en France je reste plus que jamais
convaincu du caractère indispensable de
la relation entre nos deux pays
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés au
plus grand défi de notre époque
nous continuons
à travailler pour poursuivre les travaux
de ceux qui nous ont précédés lorsque le
général de Gaulle cette adressé au
peuple français depuis Londres en juin
1940 il a dit la chose suivante
rappelez-vous la chose suivante la
France n'est pas seule elle n'est pas
isolée elle peut faire bloc avec les
Britanniques
[Musique]
avant l'appel du 18 juin
politique indissoluble qui aurait permis
à se battre pour la justice et la
liberté en tant qu'un seul pays
deux mois seulement après cette radio
Diffusion historique mon grand-père
[Musique]
rouge de la Légion d'honneur a rejoint
de Gaulle un mort volcan à côté d'un de
choc afin de passer en revue
2500 soldats des Forces Françaises
Libres
la détermination commune qui a été
exprimée ce jour-là
douloureuses de la guerre et nous ont
mené ensemble vers la victoire
de notre engagement envers la liberté et
la démocratie reste d'actualité
sont très ensemble au sein de la fausse
expéditionnelle conjointe
franco-britannique se déploie ensemble
avec les troupes de maintien de la pays
de l'ONU et par le Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU le G7 et le temps
assume ensemble une sensibilité jointe
pour la sécurité européenne et mondiale
aujourd'hui
plus de 91 depuis que nous ne sommes pas
tous côte à côte pour la libération de
l'Europe nous faisons face encore une
fois à une agression injustifiée sur
notre continent
notre détermination et notre alliance
sont plus importantes
importantes que jamais
ensemble nous nous tenons aux côtes de
peuple ukrainien avec une solidarité
résolue
ensemble nous sommes inébranlables dans
notre détermination que l'Ukraine Trion
fera et que nos libertés si chers nous
porteront
nous devons ensemble
afin de protéger le monde de ce défi
existentiel le plus grand défi de tous à
savoir le réchauffement climatique le
changement climatique et la destruction
catastrophique de la nature
pour la maille partie de l'histoire
l'homme a du combattre la nature pour se
vivre
dans ce siècle il commence à comprendre
que pour se vivre il doit la protéger
cette vision et donc plus pertinente en
ceinture
malgré l'ampleur et la sévérité du défi
auquel notre planète est confrontée
il est encore gentil de voir les mesures
prises par nos gouvernements nous
citoyens et de plus en plus par le
secteur privé
je pense depuis longtemps que nous
entreprises peuvent jouer un rôle
essentiel en travaillant en partenariat
et on amené avec nos gouvernements et
nos populations et investir des
milliards pour développer les solutions
qui peuvent être une transition réussie
vers un monde durable
avec le président Macron seront contre
cet après-midi des chefs d'entreprise
français et britanniques dont la
collaboration l'innovation et les
investissements dans une croissance
propre et la préservation de notre
précieuse biodiversité font partie d'un
lit de chef mondial essentiel
j'ai réfléchi aux opportunités que
partage les membres du communisme et de
l'Organisation internationale de la
Francophonie
j'espère vivement qu'il y aura des
possibilités de collaboration futur par
exemple pour trouver une façon de
renforcer la corporation matière de
développement durable
de défis à l'échelle mondiale néanmoins
comme toujours ce sont nos peuples qui
sont le véritable moteur de notre
relation
notre amitié et nos liens chaleureux se
renforcent à chaque nouveau contact
entre nous
également dans cette joie que l'on
retrouve à chaque fois dans la culture
de l'autre et cela nous rappelle à
chaque fois combien nous partageons de
choses des millions d'entre nous se
rendent dans nos pays respectifs chaque
année et c'est une joie que nous
redécouvrons aujourd'hui après la
pandémie
des dizaines de milliers de fans de
rugby britanniques
suivent actuellement leur équipe
nationale partout en France et ils
peuvent ainsi jouir du spectacle de
fantastique qu'elle a coupe du monde de
rugby d'ailleurs mon fils à ma
belle-fille en font partie
nationale se font face sur le terrain
elles le font
en faisant preuve d'admiration mutuelle
et en portant le même respect aux règles
du jeu et d'ailleurs je dirais
simplement pas de kuba et que le
meilleur gagne
[Applaudissements]
de nos concitoyens qui ont décidé de
s'établir de façon permanente dans nos
pays respectifs
plus heureux et plus prospère
des autres comme ils l'ont toujours fait
mêlant l'ancien et le nouveau et créant
tes œuvres complexes et enrichissantes
des inoubliables images ce Londres de
Claude Monet et de bruit à londonienne
qui fascinait tant les visiteurs
français
au plus récentes représentation sur
iPad début octni des paysages changeants
de Normandie en passant par la
collaboration de votre fils entre le
design impritannique pour Smet et le
musée Picasso à Paris il existe une
université dans notre décision
artistique protégé
en effet en ce moment même ma chère
épouse célèbre cette collaboration
artistique en lançant le premier prix
les élèves franco-britannique qui
récompense des œuvres de fiction que
temporelle exceptionnelle publiée en
français et en anglais à
l'extraordinaire Bibliothèque nationale
de France
Bristol c'était en 1947 ce lien commun
la grande quantité de connexion qui
existe entre nos villes nos villages nos
communautés nos entreprises et nos
établissements d'enseignements ce sont
nos pauvres grâce à toutes ces actions
afin que nous puissions léguer aux
prochaines générations un monde au plus
prospère à plus sûr et les jeunes
doivent donc être au cœur de nos
entreprises communes
ce matin je me réjouis donc de rejoindre
des jeunes de 19e arrondissement de
Paris et de Saint-Denis qui sont aidés
dans leur incessions professionnelles
par le biais d'initiative societe
en soutenant des jeunes nous
investissons dans notre avenir
à un investissement qui sert à remporté
Dinan d'innombrables fois
mais c'est le président madame la
Présidente Mesdames suisses et messieurs
les sénateurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés
il y a près de 120 ans
le roi Edward 7
c'est engagé au nombre de
codiale et le lien entre nos deux pays
ce lien fut sanctifié par les sacrifices
incommensurables du siècle dernier et
polype de notre projet commun
aujourd'hui
il est donc sur nos mains après avoir
été transmis avec fierté de père en
fille de mère en fils tout comme il a
été à travers les générations de ma
propre famille
pendant le temps qui met un code et en
tant que roi je m'engage à faire tout ce
qui est mon pouvoir et dans mon pouvoir
pour renforcer la relation indispensable
entre le Royaume-Uni et la France
et aujourd'hui je vous invite à vous
joindre à moi dans cet effort
ensemble notre potentiel est illimitée
c'est pourquoi nous devons sérieux
et entretenir notre en tant que
renouvelons la pour les générations
futures afin qu'elles deviennent je le
propose également une entente pour la
dirigibilité pour répondre plus
efficacement à l'Agence mondiale en
matière de climat et de biodiversité
l'engagement les uns envers les autres
et envers les valeurs que nous partons
c'est fièrement un engagement inspiré
par l'exemple du passé et ont corrigé à
relever les immenses des filles du monde
qui nous entourent
en tant que voisins amis partenaire et
allié il n'y a pas de défi que nous ne
puissions relever comme nous l'avons
fait si souvent par le passé
allons de l'avant avec espoir et courage
et faisons-le ensemble
merci
[Applaudissements]
et de resserrer
et on voit l'ovation l'ovation de
l'hémicycle du Sénat député et
parlementaire réunis qui applaudissent
ce discours de Charles III on va
évidemment revenir longuement sur le
discours du roi ainsi que sur ce des
présidents des deux assemblées d'abord
peut-être un mot sur la forme on sait
que le roi est très ponctuel alors là
tout le monde a débordé sur ses horaires
long discours
superbe et politique alors la politique
était extrêmement présente l'amitié la
politique tout y est passé du trade les
problèmes très importants les problèmes
de défense parce que il y a quelque
chose qui marche bien avec le
Royaume-Uni dans le cadre de nos accords
ce sont les accords de défense donc il
en a parlé l'amitié de mes bilan
l'entente cordiale ensemble notre
potentiel est illimité
donc voilà c'est on va parler du fond on
écoute juste encore un petit peu
ici déjà tout doucement qui nous
feraient rêver madame la Présidente et
moi-même dans nos hémicycles respectifs
désespérons pas monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
mesdames et messieurs merci de rester un
instant votre place pendant que la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
moi-même allons reconduire sa Majesté en
le remerciant de sa présence ce matin
devant député sénateurs dans cette
émission merci
voilà le roi le roi Charles III
longuement applaudit par les
parlementaires réunis au Sénat à avant
de parler du fond un autre petite un
autre petit détail qui n'en est pas un
évidemment c'est symbolique un discours
moitié en français moitié en anglais oui
qui montre bien cette volonté affichée
par tous par les trois intervenants de
de renforcer cette amitié et qu'elle
soit réciproque qu'elle soit
c'est-à-dire dialectique et ça c'était
très très frappant y compris dans les
alors dans le fond des discours mais
vous savez sur la forme au fond le fait
que chacun d'entre eux est un petit peu
dépassé même beaucoup leur temps de
parole au fond c'est le signe de le
rattachement à ce qui était en train de
se passer de l'importance qui est
désaccordait c'est un petit entorse au
protocole mais je trouve qu'elle est au
contraire très très encourageante parce
que elle donne quelque chose de très
spontané finalement à cette à cette Céré
chacun avait envie véritablement de dire
des choses chacun d'ailleurs à donner
une tonalité particulière
il y a une Brown Pivet avec un petit
passage sur les femmes qui étaient un
passage presque féministe rendant
hommage aux suffragettes
Gérard Larcher lui en soulignant
l'importance des territoires à la
tension au territoire qu'il reliait
d'ailleurs à la préoccupation
environnementale et évidemment le roi
Charles en insistant beaucoup sur cette
procucificité de la durabilité l'entente
durable c'est à dire autour de des
enjeux écologiques des enjeux de
protection de la nature qui lui tiennent
à cœur donc chacun a mis un petit peu sa
patte sur ses discours mais tous l'ont
fait je trouve moi avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasme beaucoup de chaleur on
voit sur ces images en direct la voiture
de Charles III qui l'attend dans le
jardin du Luxembourg le roi Charles qui
était arrivé par la présidence du Sénat
qui sortira donc de l'autre côté du
Sénat dans le jardin du Luxembourg où il
devrait arriver dans quelques minutes
l'hémicycle est situé à un étage au
dessus voilà donc il y a un étage à
descendre pour pour le roi pour Gérard
Larcher pour y aller brune Pivet
évidemment ce discours on l'a vu c'était
une ode à l'amitié franco-britannique le
roi Charles l'a dit le Royaume-Uni c'est
un des alliés les plus proches et des
meilleurs amis de la France parce
qu'elle Joan ah oui alors on a eu une
grande envolée sur les liens qui
unissent nos deux pays quoi qu'il arrive
et en dépit du brexit et je rappellerai
quand même que il a commencé par les
questions en effet de liberté on voit
bien que sur l'Ukraine il y a pas une
une différence entre la France et le
Royaume-Uni on a en effet tous les deux
été le rappelant le combat pour la
liberté qui a une ligne aux deux pays on
a en effet aujourd'hui quand bien même
le Royaume-Uni a quitté l'Union
européenne la guerre en Ukraine ils y
sont très sensibles il y a beaucoup de
Premier ministre et on a vu que les les
efforts pour aider l'Ukraine en matière
de défense mais c'est quand même la
France et le Royaume-Uni qui en ont fait
le plus d'abord parce que c'est des pays
qui ont le plus dépensé pour leur
défense jusqu'à une période récente ça a
changé avec la guerre en Ukraine
notamment pour l'Allemagne et d'autres
pays on a des accords vous l'avez
rappelé des accords bilatéraux
c'est-à-dire que ils sont quittés
l'Union européenne en matière de défense
c'est pas grand chose en matière
européenne quoi que ça commence à venir
depuis la guerre en Ukraine voilà ces
accords bilatéraux depuis 2010 et donc
ils n'ont pas été écornés par le fait
que le Royaume-Uni ait quitté l'Union
européenne donc on a sur cette question
des libertés des valeurs fondamentales
en effet un combat qui fait que combien
même le Royaume-Uni a quitté l'Union
européenne il y a en effet des liens et
puis il a laissé entendre en effet que
ces liens devaient être renforcés sur
des questions qui concernent la
durabilité la durabilité au niveau de
l'environnement puis mettre beaucoup de
questions des questions énergétiques on
partage aussi certains choix notamment
en matière nucléaires quand d'autres
pays ne l'ont pas ce choix là donc on a
la possibilité de travers ce discours
sur la durabilité de trouver beaucoup de
points communs et
un message en disant il faut qu'on
continue j'aurai à le faire tant que je
suis roi mais ça va durer au-delà il y a
une espèce d'éternité et en effet on
sent que ce roi invite les Européens à
travailler ensemble et les Français les
Français et les Anglais en particulier
moi j'ai des frappé par le fait qu'il a
repris l'idée du président Larcher d'une
sorte de partenariat entre les pays
francophones et les pays du Commonwealth
ça me semble assez nouveau et le roi a
repris exactement cette idée et donc
voilà derrière non seulement un
partenariat entre français et
britannique mais également beaucoup plus
large entre les pays du commonweiss il
est quand même chef d'État de
pays du Commonwealth le roi et les pays
francophones et pour continuer à tisser
ce lien c'est ce qu'a dit le roi il a
évoqué sa mère la reine Elizabeth II un
fil d'or a-t-il dit dont il espère
qu'elle va continuer à nous inspirer
c'est ce qu'il a dit pour tisser le lien
entre la France et le Royaume-Uni pour
moi c'est le renouvellement le plus
chaleureux avec une formidable mise à
jour de l'entente cordiale si l'avenir
il a magnifiquement construit je trouve
c'est un discours formidable oui c'est
très intéressant en fait de partir de
l'histoire et de nos combats mutuels
communs contre
les dictatures les régimes autoritaires
les régimes totalitaires de partir de de
cette histoire là pour se donner de
nouveaux combats de nouveaux objectifs
c'est ce qui c'est ça a été sa démarche
en partant de sa mère comme fil d'or
justement pour se donner de nouveaux
objectifs qui restent la lutte contre
les régimes privatifs de liberté
Vladimir Poutine en ligne de mire la
lutte la guerre en Ukraine dans tous les
esprits dès la défense de la démocratie
et aussi ce nouveau combat qui va
devenir le combat majeur pour beaucoup
de démocratie qui est celui de la
protection de la nature de la transition
écologique de la durabilité etc donc
c'était très intéressant de voir cette
cette démarche on part de quelque chose
qui était des combats militaires des
combats patriotiques pour la défense de
la démocratie et cette défense de la
démocratie on va désormais la porter sur
d'autres champs et notamment sur ce
change je répète qui tient au cœur de de
Charles qui est la défense de
l'environnement la protection de notre
planète et on va venir parce
qu'évidemment il y a fait référence mais
juste être un mot sur l'Ukraine parce
que on se demandait est-ce qu'il y aura
un message un peu politique
il a été très clair il a rappelé la
détermination de Paris et de Londres à
soutenir
et la démocratie et la liberté quand il
parle de démocratie et de liberté il
cite le général de Gaulle quand il parle
de la nature ici
Cousteau le commandant Cousteau et c'est
longuement et puis il nous a dit à la
fin qu'il allait aller dans le 19e à 19e
pardon arrondissement pour rencontrer
des jeunes en difficulté dans ça c'est
le côté associatif et on sait que le roi
Charles est toute sa famille font
énormément pour les gens pauvres disons
d'une certaine manière sur l'amitié
franco-britannique peut-être je voudrais
vous faire agir une phrase de Gérard
Larcher cette fois Pascal joie non parce
que Gérard Larcher il a dit le destin du
Royaume-Uni est intimement lié au
continent européen le brexit n'y a rien
changé oui je pense en effet que on a
ils ont sorti une institution
international qui est une première mais
ils sont toujours sur le territoire
européen et je sens que nous avons
besoin de régler la relation alors elle
était très conflictuelle au début et on
a besoin aujourd'hui de de
on va juste pardon je vous interrompre
on regarde ces images en direct du roi
Charles qui quitte donc le Sénat
toujours sous la pluie accompagné par le
président Gérard Larcher par Gaëlle
brune Pivet qui quitte donc le Sénat par
le jardin du Luxembourg et la reine
Kamila et là c'était pas vraiment prévu
au programme Camilla j'en ai cas elle
était avec Brigitte Macron ce matin pour
lancer un prix littéraire
franco-britannique et elle a donc
rejoint le roi Charles au Sénat ce qui
me paraît un excellent vecteur en effet
mais comme ils ont pris beaucoup plus de
temps elle était en avance donc voilà
en effet on voit que le brexit n'y
change rien c'est-à-dire qu'on a
l'obligation de travailler avec les
Britanniques et les Britanniques de
travailler avec les Européens et ce
voyage encore une fois on l'a dit et
redit c'est symbolique parce que c'est
en effet sur le territoire du continent
européen que le froid Charles fait son
premier voyage à l'étranger et au-delà
de l'Ukraine il y avait aussi un message
sur la lutte en Afrique parce qu'il y a
en effet des problèmes militaires des
problèmes en effet de de et donc on voit
bien que il y avait deux fronts il y
avait le front ukrainien sur les
dictatures et les régimes autoritaires
et sur des régimes qui sont pas
forcément des dictatures
le départ c'est le départ de du roi
Charles III du Sénat et de la reine
Kamina et ça c'est quand même important
un petit mot quand même j'en décarte sur
la présence de la reine qui n'était pas
prévue ça montre une fois de plus
l'important c'est de Camilla au côté de
Charles III
c'est tout c'est ce qui avait compris la
reine Elizabeth en les mariant en 5 en
disant je le rappelle qu'ils avaient
connu de nombreux obstacles mais courus
tous les obstacles comme un grand
stipelche
la reine Kamilla a un rôle important à
jouer auprès de son mari elle le fait
discrètement elle a toujours été très
discrète elle est passée d'une personne
qu'on détestait les Britanniques à une
personne que les Britanniques adorent et
tout ça c'est passé discrètement sans
rien mais j'ajoute que la femme du
Prince de Galles donc la princesse de
Galles elle-même un rôle très important
auprès de son mari qui est donc elle a
un rôle formidable et bon lui
prince William on voit qu'il fait très
bien son travail mais on a l'impression
que ça l'ennui un peu de temps en temps
mais elle est toujours parfaite à côté
de lui et voilà le rôle des femmes
Camilla est passé
de t'accuser d'être la femme la plus
méchante du royaume
aujourd'hui c'est
romanesque la belle grand-mère
Barbara Cartland n'aurait pas elle-même
osé inventer une situation ramonesque
par on va aller dans l'hémicycle on
rejoint Quentin calmé Quentin je le
rappelle un public Sénat la seule caméra
autorisée à être dans l'hémicycle
Quentin racontez-nous ce qui s'est passé
dans les mystique pendant le discours du
roi alors que les derniers sénateurs et
députés sont en train de quitter
l'hémicycle du Sénat effectivement
Oriane et oui vous parliez d'un d'une
Aude à l'amitié franco-britannique et
bien c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'on a
ressenti un long hommage à cette amitié
avec d'ailleurs cette ce message
prononcé dès le début de ce discours qui
nous a été d'ailleurs remis en tribune
de presse mais dès le début de son
discours le roi a annoncé la couleur il
a dit tout simplement je cite le
Royaume-Uni sera toujours un des alliés
les plus proches et un des meilleurs
amis de la France c'était dès les
premières minutes de son allocution et
on a retenu aussi partir du moment
d'émotions lorsque le Souverain a évoqué
la mort de sa maman de sa mère la reine
Elizabeth il a dit ce matin j'ai relu il
est très touchant mot de condoléances de
vos excellence président de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat que vous avez
écrit à cette occasion et il a ajouté je
ne peux vous décrire ce que ces mots en
signifiait pour moi et pour ma famille
je peux seulement vous remercier et
remercier le peuple de France pour la
grande bonté que vous avez exprimé à
notre égard parmi les messages
politiques que vous étiez en train de
commencer à évoquer en plateau on
retiendra à cet extrait consacré à la
gare en Ukraine on écoute cet extrait
ensemble nous nous tenons au côte de
peuple uranium avec une solidarité
résolue
ensemble nous sommes inébranlables dans
notre détermination que l'Ukraine
triomphera et que nos libertés si nous
porteront et voilà et donc ça c'est pour
le message politique la guerre en
Ukraine et effectivement on a entendu
ensuite ce message consacré au
réchauffement climatique à la lutte
contre ce réchauffement climatique et le
roi Charles III qui a expliqué que les
entreprises privées devaient jouer un
rôle pouvaient jouer un rôle dans cette
lutte c'était son message sur ce dossier
du réchauffement climatique me retiendra
bien entendu c'est cette longue haute à
l'amitié franco-britannique et SDR c'est
ce qui a conclu ce discours en écoutant
un deuxième extrait
content que voisin ami partenaire et
alliés il n'y a pas de défi que nous ne
puissions relever comme nous l'avons
fait si souvent par le passé
allons de l'avant avec espoir et courage
et faisons-le ensemble
merci
voilà et donc le Charles Charles
de longues secondes par et bien la
totalité des sénateurs est députés
présents ici dans l'hémicycloréenne
merci Quentin évidemment on reviendra
vers vous avant la fin de cette émission
Jean Gary oui nous l'avons dit depuis
tout à l'heure il y a une dimension
quand même très politique à ce à cette
intervention de du roi Charles moi je
vois trois points importants le dernier
celui qui vient d'être évoqué c'est
cette encouragement cet exhortation à
aller plus loin sur le terrain de la
transition écologique de défendre
l'environnement etc c'est un peu une
incantation une exhortation pour ceux
qui gouvernent y compris peut-être en
Angleterre et en France
deuxièmement la question du brexit ou la
question de la relation ou de rapport
avec avec l'Europe dans une Angleterre
et dans une France où vous n'ignerez pas
qu'il y a des forces politiques qui sont
très hostiles à la construction
européenne et qui ont même fait leur
cheval de bataille voir leur fonds de
commerce c'est un message qui n'est
quand même pas
et puis ce message ce troisième message
aussi qui est important sur l'Ukraine
c'est à dire la solidarité la défense
absolue d'un certain nombre de principes
démocratiques là encore
l'opinion publique française et un
certain nombre de partis politiques
français ont exprimé un certain nombre
de réticences face à cette défense des
principes démocratiques les valeurs
démocratiques de l'Ukraine donc moi j'y
vois quand même des un certain nombre de
politiques très très marquée
elle dit sans enfer c'est tout en fait
on imagine pas la reine Elizabeth dire
un tel discours ce n'est pas possible et
je suis certain que dans la presse
britannique on lui fera des reproches de
même que la presse britannique par
exemple a fait des reproches parce que
le roi avait accueilli
Ursula Vanden à prendre du thé bon en
disant mais comment il fait de la
politique la présidente de la Commission
européenne et cetera et tout c'est pas
vrai pas du tout c'était simplement un
geste de courtoisie là c'est de la
politique totalement et c'est une
rupture là c'est une rupture avec
Elisabeth III il faut voir aussi que
dans les sondages tels qu'ils sont fait
au Royaume-Uni on voit que de plus en
plus de Britanniques
est quasiment les deux tiers maintenant
ce disque ce vote qu'ils ont fait en
2016 il le considère comme une erreur et
donc à partir de là le roi Charles qui
la presse se dit mais mon peuple qui a
voté souverainement etc personne n'a
oublié est en train de dire j'ai fait
une erreur donc lui peut pas le faire
c'est une conviction personnelle là pour
le coup c'est une conception personnelle
je ne peux pas le faire moi parce que
c'est pas moi qui est au Royaume-Uni est
chargé de conduire la politique du
gouvernement mais je laisse un message
dans ce discours et je laisse à mes amis
français qui sont nos principales
voisins ce message d'espoir tout n'est
pas vain et on va continuer à travailler
ensemble on y mettra peut-être du temps
et on voit quand même aussi que les
Britanniques les dirigeants britanniques
que ce soit richissonnac aujourd'hui
Premier ministre ou Kerch Tamer qui est
donc le leader de l'opposition sont
aussi d'adopter ce de changer un peu
leur discours parce qu'il voit bien que
ce qui a été la réalité en 2016 a été
une était une tromperie et que donc il
va bien falloir qu'il gère et je leur
souhaite bien libre on sera là à leur
côté ne les ont pas tomber et je vous
dis ils commencent à revenir dans
certains programmes européens c'était le
programme de recherche on imagine très
bien d'autres programmes sur lesquels il
reviendrait parce que nous avons besoin
des Britanniques en Europe il y a
beaucoup de défis et en effet ces défis
ne sont pas que des défis internationaux
mais il y en a beaucoup qui sont
internationaux là on a besoin d'avoir
une forme
était revenue avec son chapeau
européenne est-ce que ça veut dire quand
on écoute ce discours qu'il y a un style
Charles III
et dans un français bien senti la partie
française je trouve remarquable bien
sincère bien ancré et qui lui correspond
tout à fait différent de celui de sa
mère ça te fait absolument aucun doute
et donc voilà il dit les choses telles
qu'il a envie de les dire il est dit
bien donc c'est là où on lui fera
peut-être pas trop de reproche on lui en
fera quand même sans aucun doute et il
dit véritablement que le partenariat
entre nos deux pays non seulement c'est
une bonne chose mais qu'il doit aller
beaucoup plus loin et ça c'est il
réussit à se mettre dans les pas de sa
mère parce qu'encore une fois il a
évoqué il avait déjà évoqué hier au de
Versailles mais en imprimant sa masse
et ça a toujours été quelqu'un qui était
passionné par le débat public la vie
politique et on intervenant même mais de
manière plus plus secrète et avec des
premiers ministres qu'il a contacté à
l'époque etc Tony Blair par exemple mais
là il prend dans sa stature de de roi
avec les précoces les précautions
d'usage le style d'un monarque il il
donne des des indications très précises
sur sa conception de de la démocratie de
d'une Europe démocratique des valeurs
qu'il faut défendre et des combats à
mener je trouve que ce ce y compris
cette incantation je dirais aller plus
loin dans notamment le développement
durable etc la défense de de
l'environnement c'est quelque chose qui
marque véritablement et qui est
effectivement qui est le style de
Charles qui est le différencie de des
d'une autre époque était celle de sa
mère
juste avant qu'il rentre dans
l'hémicycle et une espèce de
décontraction qu'on aurait pas imaginé
du temps de sa mère avec le président de
l'Assemblée du et de la président de
l'Assemblée nationale qui était plutôt
joviale détendu lui-même n'étant pas
vraiment et les parlementaires etc et
puis dans le discours moi je trouve
quand même que ce petit moment où il a
évoqué la Coupe du monde de rugby parce
qu'elle se tient chez nous avec en effet
lui trois équipes puisqu'il y a
l'Angleterre le Pays de Galles et les
causes puisque c'est des nations
différentes donc nous avons en effet il
a trois raisons peut-être d'imaginer que
ils peuvent battre les français même si
on va pas le laisser plaisir et là
peut-être en effet l'entendre on sait
qu'au rugby il y a certains fierté
qu'après avoir chaque match il y a une
entente entre les joueurs qu'on ne
trouve pas dans d'autres Emmanuel Macron
l'avait fait il a évoqué également le
rugby gentleman exactement
quand les Anglais aplatissent un essai
sauf qu'on sait contre nos bleus moi sur
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure comme
c'est une visite d'État il ne fait aucun
doute que son discours a été vu par le
Premier ministre et par le gouvernement
c'est donc le
roi Charles III donc chef d'État du
Royaume-Uni avec l'aval du gouvernement
qui vient de prononcer ses paroles et
c'est ça qui est très important
un dernier mot très rapidement
jean-garrick parce que au début il a
fait un petit trait d'humour alors à
Charles en disant mais ma visite précède
votre entrée mes excuses d'avoir
interrompu votre pause faut dire que
pour certains sénateurs présents c'était
leur dernière séance
ce qui marque aussi sa connaissance et
sa volonté de marquer son respect
vis-à-vis de la vie parlementaire
française merci à tous son dimanche donc
en effet la séance
merci à tous merci d'avoir été avec nous
on va remonter vos différents ouvrages
Pascal Jouannin le rapport de la
Fondation Robert Schuman merci beaucoup
parce Pascal d'avoir été notre invité
Jean Gary jour heureux quand les
Français rêvaient ensemble Philippe
parois merci également d'avoir été avec
nous un écran dans ma vie et puis j'en
déclare merci beaucoup Charles Camilla
et Diana amour et tragédie chez les
Windsor merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis on va voir quelques images
quelques temps forts de cette matinée je
remercie Quentin également d'avoir été
avec nous dans l'hémicycle et de nous
avoir permis de tout voir tout savoir de
ce qui s'est passé durant ce discours du
roi et on revoit voilà on se quitte sur
ces images sur ces temps forts de la
visite du roi Charles III merci à tous
de nous avoir